let's think about whether each of these
expressions produce rational or
irrational numbers and this is a
reminder a rational number is one so if
you have a rational number X it can be
it can be expressed as the ratio of two
integers m and N and if you have an
irrational number this cannot this
cannot happen so let's let's think about
each of these so 9 is clearly a rational
number you can express 9 as 9 over 1 or
18 over 2 or 27 over 3 so it can clearly
be expressed as the ratio of two
integers but what about the square root
of 45 so let's think about that a little
bit square root of 45 that's the same
thing as the square root of 9 times 5
which is the same thing as the square
root of 9 times the square root of 5 the
principal root of 9 is 3 so it's 3 times
the square root of 5 so this is going to
be 9 plus 3 times the square root of 5
so square root of 5 is irrational you're
taking the square root of a non perfect
square right over here irrational
3 is rational but the product of a
rational and an irrational is still
going to be irrational so that's going
to be irrational and then you're taking
a irrational number and you're adding 9
to it you're adding a rational number to
it but you add a rational to an
irrational and you're still going to
have an irrational so this whole thing
this whole thing is irrational
irrational now let's think about now
let's think about this this expression
right over here well the numerator can
be rewritten as the square root of 9
times 5 over 3 times the square root of
5 well that's the same thing as the
square root of 9 times the square root
of 5 over 3 times the square root of 5
well that's the same thing as 3 times
the square root of 5 over 3 times the
square root of 5 well that's just going
to be equal to 1 or you can view this 1
over 1 and one is clearly a rational
number you can write it as 1 over 1 2
over 2 3 over 3 really any integer over
itself so this is going to be rational
now let's do this last expression right
over here
times the principal root of nine but
what's the principal root of nine plus
three so this is going to be 3 times 3
which is equal to 9 and we've already
talked about the fact that mine can
clearly be expressed as the ratio of two
integers 9 over 1 27 over 3 45 over 5
all different forms of different ways of
expressing 9